- Guten Tag, Frau Broichhagen.
- Guten Tag.
- Die Firma Schöllgen. Mein Name
ist Hemme. Das ist der Kollege Mandt.
Wir sind hier für die Badsanierung, wir
legen heute die Fußbodenheizung.
- Ja, schön, schön, dass ihr da
seid. Kommt bitte rein.
- Danke schön.
- So, Andreas, wir sind hier
jetzt in dem Badezimmer.
- Ja.
- Wir haben folgende Situation:
Wir haben da vorne den Waschtisch,
hier kommt das WC hin.
Und wir sind heute hier, um
die Fußbodenheizung zu legen.
- Alles klar.
- Wir haben die Fußbodenheizung
verlegt, wir haben sie angeschlossen,
und sie ist dicht. Und damit sind
wir fertig für heute.
- Ja, klasse. Vielen Dank.
- Ich hab jetzt Ihnen den Zettel fertig
gemacht. Das bin ich, das ist der Kollege.
Heute, und wir waren jetzt insgesamt
drei Stunden hier gewesen.
Wir haben die Fußbodenheizung verlegt,
angeschlossen und auf
Dichtigkeit überprüft.
Und dann bekomme ich bitte hier
unten eine Unterschrift von Ihnen.
- Sind das jetzt insgesamt
dann sechs Stunden oder?
- Drei Stunden für jeden.
Also insgesamt sechs Stunden.
- Wo soll ich unterschreiben?
- Da unten bitte, beim Kreuz.
- Ja, danke schön.
- Vielen Dank Ihnen.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen
noch einen schönen Tag.
- Danke schön, gleichfalls.
- Tschüss.
- Bis dahin, tschüss!